biofuels will increasingly power
tomorrow's vehicles but growing fuel
crops has side effects like indirect
land usage change which can also impact
on climate that's why Emmy pees on the
European Parliament's Environment
Committee want to encourage new types of
more sustainable biofuels effort over
Nikki limo or Collette Landry street
obesity don't only ears ago fuel de la
première generación la necessity do he
knows emissions SFX a two-tone investee
so Shirley's a kookaburra newseum
genesee the vote has been welcomed by
environmental campaigners we think they
have refocused the market on those
biofuels which we think we need for the
future which are more advanced biofuels
supposed to save more emissions and
being less severe for environment and
people because they use less land the EU
is committed to ten percent of transport
being fueled from renewable sources by
2020 but fears about consequences that M
eps that amount only 5.5 percent from
crops the rest from non-food sources
like waste but that has put up the price
of used cooking oil people were buying
palm oil which you know means cutting
down rain forests in places like
Indonesia to grow palm trees to produce
palm oil the palm oil was being imported
into Europe used to fry a few chips and
then sold at a profit that's cooking oil
there are new sources this French
company produces biodiesel from
fermented algae it's new technology a
so-called third generation solution but
it works it's developments like this
that the report aims to encourage the
new investment program of the UD horizon
2020 puts a lot of money in research for
the second generation like I gay like
other chemicals that can produce energy
any Peas want to see more sustainable
biofuels being used in transport but
without negative environmental or social
effects the report was passed but they
still face a battle when it goes before
a full cleaner recession Incept